let's jump to this next story because
this one's pretty shocking we have this
from the post millennial Carlson was
told by a member of the fox board that
he was taken off the air as part of the
Dominion settlement per Tucker's legal
team two people briefed in the
conversation told axios that Carlson had
been told by a fox board member that he
was taken off the air abruptly that last
month as part of a settlement with
Dominion voting systems the 787 million
settlement million dollar settlement for
each of the two parties came less than a
week after it was revealed Carlson was
off the air in a letter from Carlson's
lawyers to Fox News they argue that
Carlson's non-compete clause in his
contract which runs through 2025 is no
longer valid alleging Fox employees
including Robert Murdoch himself broke
promises to Carlson intentionally and
with Reckless disregard for the truth
the lawyers accused Fox Executives with
two uh which two sources told axios are
Viet den and Murdoch of making material
misrepresentations or promises to
Carlson that was intentionally broken
constituting fraud the Revelation comes
as Tucker Carlson has launched a new
show on Twitter so it's kind of crazy
the reporting that Dominion basically
told Fox you've got a fire Tucker
Carlson and then why would they do it
let's break this down you gotta fire
Tucker Carlson and almost a billion
dollars but consider this
yeah I do a contract with somebody they
can't abruptly fire me without cause
contracts will have terms and if you do
your contract right it gives you some
protections so I've done contracts
before with networks and they've all
said if you terminate the show remove
him or in any way inhibit his work it
will constitute a a you know a breach of
contract and you know party will be
responsible for paying out the full
amount of the contract you know there
and or whatever so if you do a contract
for a million bucks over three years and
then six months in they say your show's
off there you gotta pay me the million
bucks right now that is the contract
agreement and so typically they don't
like to do that to break this contract
with Tucker Carlson
implies Dominion was going after more
money so so basically the cost benefit
analysis comes in and Fox News says how
much money will we lose if we defy
Dominion is it going to be another 100
200 300 million how much do we lose if
Tucker sues us
fire Talker by the way I could be
mistaken here but if I'm correct Tucker
wasn't really blaming Dominion he was
the election outcomes yes it was this is
the crazy thing about it Tucker is the
guy who said to Sydney Powell come on my
show and I'll give you all the time in
the world to prove your claims where's
the evidence and he got attacked by
Trump supporters for it so why would
Dominion want him out I don't know
because maybe the people who work at
Dominion are just cult members and
they're like here's our opportunity to
strike at the heart of Fox News
they would lump all dissident
conservatives in under the category of
election denial or whatever whatever
label they're using no let me ask you
guys this question
why won't the left go after Hannity
why why is Tucker Carlson the target
despite the fact that Tim Carlson
overlaps with the left on a ton of
issues because he's moving the Overton
window populism yep economic populism
anti-war yet they attack him exclusively
he's the closest to anti-government like
Sean Hannity is is not anti-government
at any you know by any stretch of the
imagination he'll talk about small
government but Sean Hannity is the
as typical of a republican that as as
you can probably get Tucker Carlson for
all his
for all the fact that he used to be a
Democrat like back in the day and and
I'm sure that he's comfortable with a
big with a with a fairly large
government too he's still
anti-establishment so even if he's he
would want a big government he doesn't
want the type of big government that we
have now so I imagine that's why he gets
the heat that he does didn't Tucker
Carlson recently call himself a liberal
I mean he did support Ron Paul when he
was running yeah oh yeah yeah and when
he I think when he says liberal he means
like liberal yeah right and I would say
I mean Hannity is part of the the
conservative ink cult yes you know like
and and so at some point you know the
Colts all do their own thing but don't
come after each other it's the people
who step outside of the cult outside of
the the you know the three by the
allowable uh opinion uh that that have
to be taken out and have to be you know
made out to be crazy shout out to Tom
Woods for that three by five absolutely
how did he support Ron Paul
I think he openly vocally did and I'm
pretty sure if I remember correctly when
Ron Paul spoke uh at his counter event
to the GOP National Convention that
Tucker Carlson spoke there don't quote
me on that but I think he did but he was
vocally insupportive Ron Paul well yeah
and I think they also want to go after
someone who they
perceive as weak because they're outside
of one of those bubbles right when
you're standing on your own and there
aren't going to be as many people who
have your back when they start running
hit pieces on you it's it's much easier
to take you out
I wonder how effective that will be Now
with uh you know with you know the
largest communications platform I I
maybe I don't know that's the irony he's
he he's he hasn't
like evolved into his ultimate form and
now he has the room to do that yeah I I
mean it's it's definitely going to be
you know it's definitely going to be uh
extremely interesting to see what does
happen
um I kind of smelled that he was going
to go to Twitter I was I'd been talking
about it because
musk has made comments about when he
bought Twitter he was thinking you know
there's no place like WeChat in the U.S
so like we chatting in China you can pay
for everything you can watch videos and
Etc and he when he bought Twitter he was
thinking oh I think that you know we
should make Twitter I think I think it's
gonna work I think so too yeah yeah I'm
thinking about uh there he's already
responded saying like Twitter TV app or
something like that Twitter Live app so
that you can open your TV and watch
Twitter videos people are gonna be
producing video content he's already got
the subscriptions going that's the first
thing he has to do people subscribe to
content that generates revenue for the
person which gets them to use the
platform more it generates revenue for
Twitter it puts patreon out of business
it's a big threat to rumble as well
considering he's allowing Free Speech
but I'm really excited about patreon
imploding because uh there's no way you
can compete you've got your followers on
Twitter already patreon is where you try
to direct them if they're already on
Twitter you can just click that little
button right there yeah hey you follow
me click that button boom you got a new
subscriber so it's way easier to convert
your existing fan base Elon knew this I
think him going after Twitter to buy it
in the first place it had a lot more to
do with just the than just the Babylon B
uh people were talking about how this is
actually an effective app for
communicating over long distances like
sending messages from Mars for instance
yeah exactly you post it and you let it
go and then it appears when it appears
so I think elon's got big plans I'm just
I'm just awaiting I can't stand he was
saying he was he was kind of late for
the party
um he even admitted uh after openai
launched uh gpt4 he's gonna get you know
start training his own llm he knows he's
late to the party there but you know
there's something where there's all
these pots in the fire that he's got
going that I think either he has an idea
of where they're all they may converge
in the future or he's just actually
trying out a bunch of things and seeing
what works I'm excited to see what
happens with Twitter but you know with
this llm thing what's llm the large
language models like you know GPT right
so yeah he's gonna start training his
own one he said he's going to call it
truth GPT right which you know will
basically just not have the the biases
stuff like that in there and he knows
he's behind the curve but you know if
anyone behind the curve can do it is
probably him I've been using a mid
Journey a lot you may have seen I I
posted a picture on Twitter which I
think is very important actually I'm
going to pull it up right now I think it
is one of the most important images of
this or any generation let me uh let me
just try and scroll down here and I
think it's uh I think it's going to be
right here let me pull this one over
there you go ladies and gentlemen the
most important photo America's back baby
uh for those are just listening it's a
picture of Donald Trump and Sonic the
Hedgehog running in Washington DC for
some reason and then I have this picture
of Donald Trump shaking hands with Sonic
the Hedgehog for some reason but I've
been using uh mid journey and so it is
interesting to see where we go like this
photo of Donald Trump looks real I mean
Sonic Hedgehog obviously does not look
real he's not it's not a real thing but
uh the photo of trump looks like it's
actually Trump running and we've already
seen a bunch of photos of him getting
arrested and things like that it took me
10 seconds to do this I just typed it in
as a bit Donald Trump running besides
the Hedgehog enter boom 30 seconds goes
by and it just pops up on the screen so
things are starting to get crazy
I think it'll be I don't know I want to
bring it up I think it'll be fascinating
to see where these where this AI stuff
goes especially if Elon Musk is getting
involved and especially if the Twitter
Firehouse is plugged right into the
language and learning model it's going
to create it's it's going to create some
kind of weird Borg structure a hive mind
of all of our thoughts
no oh my gosh all of our thoughts from
Twitter yeah that thing's gonna be
horrible it's just gonna be Pepe it's
gonna be just like a big problem it's
like I am incarnate I am Keck and we're
gonna be like wow it happened the dark
painting of the world as a filmmaker
they have uh Speech to Text I follow the
code report and you know a bunch of
videos like that and it's just insane
with the amount of plugins I was just
watching something today that was saying
actually it was uh it wasn't the open
letter where people were saying we need
to slow down AI it was another one
saying that the the ones who aren't
doing it open source actually are having
a big uh a hindrance because all the
open source ones seem to be evolving a
lot faster did you uh what have you
heard of that video AI That's like mid
Journey you can type in walking through
a forest during at night and it will
generate a video of walking through the
force and now you've seen that one yeah
it can do just speech to text or just
speech to um to video and it's only a
couple seconds long but just remember
anyone listening that's that's the worst
it's going to look and it doesn't look
that bad right now I've seen the videos
and it's nuts there's apps right now
where you'll have people on their phones
just filming themselves like you know
running through their house or something
like that and then within with a few
prompts and 10 seconds later the whole
landscape around turns into like you
know he's he's now wearing Indiana Jones
type stuff and the place he's in is like
an under underground catacombs or
something this is actually why another
good reason I think Twitter might end up
being the place in terms of the internet
because if it's it's a platform where
people are just sharing ideas and Elon
does get this stuff integrated we're
coming to the point where look man I'm
an artist
I made that picture of Elon I'm sorry of
Donald Trump and some Hedgehog running
in Washington DC you had a bereton as
you did it well you know if look if
someone uses a paintbrush to make an
image they're using a tool to do it we
don't it's still their image now at the
point where the the the the canvas and
the paintbrush is literally just an AI
you tell it what to make you refine it
it is your art and it feels a lot of
people probably disagree but we're not
going to be thinking that in 10 20 years
people are going to be like that was so
creative creative of you to make that
movie they're gonna be like Sheamus that
that feature-length film you made last
night was incredible I I enjoyed the
whole thing thanks I enjoyed it too no
problem I appreciate it but you're
you're going to say you're all by myself
actually they're gonna right right now
check it out they have apps where you
can animate images
you can post a picture of a person and
then type send in text or I play an
audio file and it will sync the the
photo with the audio file we've already
seen the stuff where people are singing
right we did the music video genocide
where we had like Taylor Lorenz singing
our song you can they have high
resolution versions of it someone mid
used mid journey to generate a Sci-Fi
looking spaceship Captain female then
they wrote out with uh text-to-speech
program a paragraph they then took that
audio file and put it in this program
with the image and made her talk that
was like one plus two equals three
imagine someone in a year having a
program that is all of that instantly
and then once you have those things all
you got to do is is Type in a movie
about a space Captain leaving Earth to
go find a new Colony but gets betrayed
by the first mate and then aliens come
and the first mate was working with
aliens the whole time and then it will
just render the whole movie like that
it's crazy and it's all based upon the
language models because there's a ton of
different AI models but then all of a
sudden in 2017 rolls around and the
language models start doing what the
other models weren't able to do like
language models can now do chemistry
better than chemistry AI which is
trained specifically for that
um it's starting to progress where
everyone who is in all these other camps
of AI they're only focusing on one
platform which means the progress is
going to go that much faster thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time